I already mentioned last night's Puppy
Bowl which airs every year on Animal
Planet well this year another cable
network tried to get in on the action so
many cable networks they're all
competing with each other so I don't
think this events gonna become a
Superbowl tradition I didn't think this
was as successful take a look
welcome to the first annual Food Network
produce ball it's fruits versus
vegetables and scanning the field I can
already say with confidence this event
was a terrible idea there is literally
zero gridiron action on this field
ok we're deep into the fourth quarter of
a scoreless game and the tomato has
possession he's limping awkwardly toward
the end zone and oh and here's a replay
in case anyone is still watching the
fruits have called a timeout because
their quarterback is missing
hold on can we get a shot of that sound
guy good lord the sound guy is eating
the quarterback you gotta be kidding is
this vegetables have possession and it
looks like they could oh ok great ok
there seems to be some kind of power
outage can we please get the lights back
on in here oh my there are rats on the
field oh gosh maybe they could smell the
produce rotting under those hot lights
in any case things are finally getting
interesting
[Applause]
you